angela mackel's mobile phone was  allegedly tapped by agents in the u.s  embassy what do people on the streets of  berlin think  it's outrageous it's like spying on your  wife or your best friend  it's totally unacceptable  not even the us has the right to tap  merkel's cell phone  what should the americans do now  apologize  should president obama apologize 76  percent of germans say  yes only 17 percent say he shouldn't  we need to protect ourselves germany  needs to protect itself  if they can spy on the chancellor it  makes you wonder what else is going on  behind the scenes that we have yet to  hear about  it's surprising and shocking  you can't believe it's only the  americans who would do this  do you think the russians or the british  or  60 of germans believe that the spying  scandal will harm  german u.s relations  you